Kennst du das auch?
Du triffst auf einen fremden Menschen und
denkst dir noch bevor du dich mit ihm unterhalten
hast: „Man der ist bestimmt total unfreundlich,
mit dem will ich lieber nichts zu tun haben.“
Oder ganz im Gegenteil und du hattest gleich
den Eindruck, dass er richtig kontaktfreudig
und zuvorkommend ist.
Falls ja, dann geht es dir, wie so ziemlich
jedem.
Wir fällen schnell ein Urteil über andere,
ohne sie eigentlich näher zu kennen.
Einfach nur auf Grundlage ihres Auftretens
und ihres äußeren Erscheinungsbildes.
Wie kannst du also dafür sorgen, dass andere
Menschen von dir einen absolut positiven ersten
Eindruck haben?
Heute will ich dir 5 Tipps verraten, die dir
dabei helfen werden, immer einen perfekten
ersten Eindruck zu hinterlassen.
Erstens: Sei pünktlich.
Pünktlichkeit ist essentiell für einen guten
ersten Eindruck, denn niemand wartet gern.
Diese Eigenschaft solltest du dir grundsätzlich
angewöhnen; egal ob für ein Date, Vorstellungsgespräch,
oder auch nur für eine Unterrichtsstunde.
Wenn du unpünktlich bist und eine andere
Person warten lässt, vermittelst du den Eindruck
dass sie dir nicht wichtig genug ist.
Gerade im Business-Bereich ist Pünktlichkeit
besonders bedeutsam.
Wenn man bei einem wichtigen Meeting zu spät
ist, gibt es kaum eine Entschuldigung, um
diesen ersten schlechten Eindruck wieder auszubügeln.
Plane also immer genügend Zeit ein, damit
du pünktlich bist, denn das ist die Grundlage
für einen guten ersten Eindruck.
Kommen wir jetzt zu Tipp Nummer Zwei: Eine
selbstsicheren Körpersprache.
Eine Vielzahl von Studien hat gezeigt, dass
deine Körperhaltung nicht nur deine Psyche
- also wie du dich fühlst - beeinflusst,
sondern auch wie dich andere Menschen wahrnehmen.
Wenn du zum Beispiel deine Arme verschränkst,
dein Kinn etwas einziehst, nervös mit deinem
Fuß auf den Boden klopfst und deine Beine
unter dem Stuhl überkreuzt hast, werden dich
andere als ängstlich und verschlossen wahrnehmen.
Das sind jedoch alles Angewohnheiten, die
du dir mit etwas Übung abtrainieren kannst.
Du kannst also direkt beeinflussen, ob dich
andere Menschen als Selbstbewusst wahrnehmen
und vielmehr, ob du dich auch selbstbewusster
fühlst.
Setzte dich dazu gerade hin, nimm deine Arme
und Beine etwas weiter auseinander, als ob
du… mehr Raum einnehmen wolltest.
Alleine dadurch wirst du dich schon selbstsicherer
fühlen und mehr Selbstvertrauen ausstrahlen.
Zusätzlich kannst du dein Kinn etwas anheben,
statt es in Richtung Brust zu ziehen und dir
einen aufrechten Gang angewöhnen.
Du solltest hierbei darauf achten, dass du
deine Schulten nicht einfach nach vorne hängen
lässt, sondern sie etwas zurückziehst.
Denk dir einfach: „Brust raus“.
Das hat genau den gewünschten Effekt.
Eine Körperhaltung die Selbstbewusstsein
ausstrahlt, sorgt auf jeden Fall für einen
guten ersten Eindruck.
Nachdem du also pünktlich und mit selbstbewusster
Haltung zu deinem verabredeten Treffen erscheinst,
wird dein Gegenüber als nächstes auf dein
Äußeres achten.
Tipp Nummer Drei ist deshalb das äußere
Erscheinungsbild.
Dieses lässt sich in zwei Bereich unterteilen:
Gesicht und restlicher Körper.
Fangen wir mit dem Gesicht an, denn das mustern
Menschen in der Regel zuerst.
Gelbe Zähne mit Essensresten dazwischen,
ungepflegte Haare oder ein wild wuchernder
Bart machen einen schlechten ersten Eindruck.
Das selbe gilt auch für Pickel oder allgemein
unreine Haut.
Egal wie Selbstbewusst du wirkst oder wie
pünktlich du bist, andere Menschen werden
dir weniger zutrauen, da du dich ja scheinbar
nichtmal um dein Äußeres richtig kümmern
kannst.
Natürlich ist das sehr oberflächlich und
politisch inkorrekt, aber die meisten Menschen
urteilen leider nunmal so.
Aber… formulieren wir das ganze doch mal
etwas positiver:
Mit einem modischem Haarschnitt, gepflegten
Zähnen und einer reinen Haut machst du auf
jeden Fall einen guten ersten Eindruck.
Und das sind alles Faktoren, auf die du einen
direkten Einfluss hast.
Außerdem solltest du auch deine Augenbrauen
nicht vergessen.
Und ja… das gilt auch für Männer
Gerade in Zeiten von Social Media ist das
äußere Erscheinungsbild wichtiger denn je.
Häufig sehen Menschen zuerst dein Profilbild,
bevor sie überhaupt mit dir in Kontakt treten.
Achte also auch hier auf ein vorteilhaftes
Foto.
Das Gesicht ist zwar in der Regel das Erste,
was wir bei einem anderen Menschen betrachten,
der Rest des äußeren Erscheinungsbildes
ist aber nicht weniger wichtig.
Eine sportliche Figur ist hier natürlich
nützlich, aber bedeutender ist eigentlich
die Kleidung.
Wie heißt es so schön: „Kleider machen
Leute“.
Zum Kleidungsstil lassen sich natürlich keine
allgemein gültigen Tipps geben.
Hier kommt es sehr stark auf den Kontext an.
Solange du nicht Mark Zuckerberg heißt, hat
Freizeitkleidung nichts auf einer Konferenz
oder auf einem Meeting zu suchen.
Genau wie bei einem wichtigen Vorstellungsgespräch
solltest du hier einen Anzug tragen.
Achte darauf, dass dieser auch wirklich gut
sitzt.
Der Anzug sollte nicht so locker über deinen
Schultern hängen, als ob er deinem übergewichtigem
Onkel gehören würde.
So spannend, dass die Knöpfe abplatzen sollte
er allerdings auch nicht.
Er muss eben passen.
Denk einfach mal an Barney Stinson.
Ein gut sitzender Anzug hat einfach Stil.
Falls du allerdings am Abend zu deinem besten
Kumpel gehst, weil gerade ein Fußballspiel
läuft, ist ein Anzug nicht unbedingt die
beste Wahl.
Hier bietet sich natürlich lockere Freizeitkleidung
an.
Allerdings sollte die auch gut passen.
Kurzgesagt: Gut sitzende Kleidung macht auch
einen guten ersten Eindruck.
Nachdem du also auch äußerlich einen hervorragenden
Eindruck macht, kommt es auf das zwischenmenschliche
an.
Also auf Dinge wie Blickkontakt, Sprechweise,
oder ein sympathisches Lächeln.
Fangen wir mit Tipp Nummer Vier beim Blickkontakt
an.
Sehr viel Blickkontakt… ist schlecht.
Wenn du jemanden kontinuierlich anstarrst,
wirkt das beängstigend und einfach creepy.
Zu wenig Blickkontakt ist allerdings auch
schlecht.
Sonst wirst du als verängstigt oder schüchtern
wahrgenommen.
Als guter Anhaltspunkt dient hier das Pareto-Prinzip,
auch als 80/20-Regel bekannt.
Schaue der anderen Person ca. 80% der Zeit
in die Augen und die restlichen 20% irgendwo
anders hin.
Nach Möglichkeit aber nicht verschämt auf
deine eigenen Schuhe.
Diese Zeitangaben sind selbstverständlich
nicht als ein absolutes Muss zu verstehen.
Sie sollen lediglich als grober Anhaltspunkt
dienen.
Allerdings sollte der Blickkontakt schon mehr
als 50% der Zeit ausmachen.
Weniger wirkt nervös, nicht sehr selbstsicher
und macht ganz allgemein keinen guten Eindruck.
Der letze Punkt - Nummer Fünf - ist die Sprache.
Hier möchte ich darauf eingehen, was du sagst
und wie du es sagt.
Zunächst zur Sprechweise, also wie du Dinge
sagst.
Ein laute und volle Stimme vermittelt viel
mehr Selbstvertrauen und sorgt somit für
einen besseren ersten Eindruck.
Versuche hierfür mehr aus deiner Brust zu
sprechen und nicht so sehr aus deiner Nase.
Hast du den Unterschied gehört?
Die erste Variante strahlt einfach viel mehr
Autorität und Selbtsicherheit aus.
Ein weiterer Tip ist, den Mund beim Sprechen
etwas weiter zu öffnen.
Dadurch kann der Schall besser entweichen
und deine Stimme ist automatisch lauter und
klarer.
Diese beiden Dinge kannst du leicht für dich
alleine üben.
Zum Beispiel unter der Dusche oder wenn du
sonst gerade nichts besseres zu tun hast.
Auf Dauer wird es so zu einer festen Angewohnheit
und du musst garnicht weiter darüber nachdenken.
Ganz offensichtlich ist es auch wichtig, was
du sagst.
Ein sehr weites Thema, über das man ein ganzes
Video machen könnte.
Und genau das habe ich auch vor.
In den nächsten Tagen werde ich ein Video
hochladen, wie man ein Gespräch endlos am
laufen halten kann und peinliches Schweigen
vermeidet.
Falls dich das interessiert, dann abonniere
doch den Kanal, damit du es nicht verpasst.
In diesem Video will ich mich erstmal nur
auf Füllwörter beschränken.
Ausdrücke wie Äh und hmm machen einen schlechten
Eindruck.
Selbst wenn du hm den ääh den besten Inhalt
in der äh Welt hast, niemand wird dir zuhören.
Versuche also diese Lückenfüller mit etwas
sinnvollerem zu ersetzen.
Selbst einfache Stille ist tatsächlich besser.
Wenn du nicht übermäßig viele Pausen machst……
dann kann das sogar eine gewisse Spannung
erzeugen und deine Zuhörer fesseln.
Leider… lässt sich das daheim nicht so
gut üben.
Hier hilft wirklich nur sich mit anderen Menschen
zu unterhalten und einfach bewusst zu versuchen,
diese Lückenfüller zu vermeiden.
Also… Das war jetzt eine Menge Input.
Deshalb hier nochmal ein kurze Zusammenfassung:
1.
Ein guter erster Eindruck beginnt mit Pünktlichkeit.
Lass andere nicht warten, denn das wirkt respektlos.
2.
Bemühe dich um eine selbstsichere Körperhaltung.
Versuche dich hierfür mehr zu öffnen und
mehr Raum einzunehmen.
3.
Achte auf ein gepflegtes Äußeres, denn viele
Menschen werden dich stark danach beurteilen.
4.
Halte ausreichend Blickkontakt, aber nicht
zu viel.
Das 80/20-Prinzip dient hier als guter Anhaltspunkt.
5.
Bemühe dich um eine volle und klare Stimme
indem du aus der Brust sprichst und deinen
Mund etwas mehr öffnest.
Versuche dabei so weit wie möglich auf unnötige
Füllwörter zu verzichten.
Wenn du diese Ratschläge befolgst, wirst
du garantiert einen best möglichen ersten
Eindruck hinterlassen, egal ob auf einem Date,
einem Vorstellungsgespräch oder in jeder
beliebigen Gesprächssituation.
Mit einem Daumen nach oben kannst du mir Bescheid
geben, dass du mehr Videos wie dieses hier
sehen willst.
Falls du Interesse an anderen Themen hast,
schreib mit einfach in den Kommentaren und
ich werde mich bemühen ein Video dazu machen.
Also danke fürs Zuschauen und abonniere den
Kanal für mehr!